so as we move forward into our
discussion of the Infinity Gauntlet and
warlock and the infinity watch which of
course is the event that takes place
immediately after the Infinity Gauntlet
I felt like it was important to do a
lead up to to this discussion by talking
about various characters now this first
discussion is about the one above all
and while the one above all doesn't
necessarily appear in the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline the Living Tribunal
does but in order to understand the role
that the Living Tribunal plays and the
Marvel multiverse we have to talk about
the one above all so we can have some
context and understand why the Living
Tribunal does what he does so the one
above all is an extremely obscure
character and Marvel Comics in fact the
evidence that I've uncovered all the
investigation that I've done has pointed
to the fact that the one above all has
only appeared whether by discussion or
direct appearances 17 times in the
entire publication history of Marvel
Comics which is an extremely small
number is an extraordinarily small
number especially when you consider the
idea that characters like Wolverine have
appeared in over 13,000 different comics